j'aime bien les campagnes électorales
c'est l'occasion de rencontrer les gens
c'est l'occasion de confronter les idées
c'est l'occasion de mettre son énergie
au service des autres et donc moi je
suis assez enthousiaste
le maire à qui j'ai informé que j'ai
informé avant cette conférence de presse
de ce que je serai candidat m'a dit qu
il ne sait pas encore si lui même sera
candidat s'il ne l'est pas il m'a dit
qu'il soutiendra camille marlette y aura
d'autres candidats tous ces gens là sont
mes amis tous ces gens là sont mes amis
j'ai été en classe avec certains d'entre
eux
je suis l'ami de la famille des autres
je suis l'ami tout court des autres donc
nous sommes ici dans une grande famille
je n'ai rien contre personne
je ne viens pas faire de combat
politique je ne viens pas faire de fer
combats de coqs
je viens essayer de rassembler et je
viens essayer d'apporter mon expérience
mon vécu au service de cette population
est de 7,2 ce territoire qui sont mon
territoire
ici dans cette maison que j'ai construit
il ya 40 ans